bravo monsieur vous avez la patience
écran de bois vous êtes l'homme du monde
qu'ils estiment les plus j'ai parlé de
voir ce matin à la chambre du roi on
devait beaucoup d'honneur monsieur dans
la chambre du roi un riche bourgeois qui
veut devenir un noble une source de
moquerie pour molière lorsqu'il a écrit
le bourgeois gentilhomme ici monsieur
jourdain et les différents personnages
sont joués par des lycéens de trappes
une découverte de l'importance du
costume de costumes jfx ans après qu'on
m'a donnée consomme c'est sûr que ça ça
m'a mis plus à l'aise par rapport au
personnage
ouais ça va être en mieux pal
la paire est il apte et vraiment drôle
de personnage et où ils ont préparé
plusieurs scènes extraites du bourgeois
gentilhomme et l'exercice étant
de le répéter une fois sans costume
comme dans le cas d'une répétition et
une fois avec les costumes des costumes
là
traditionnel est économiste et
historique et de voir tout ce que ça
apportait à la fois pour le public donc
pour ceux qui observait la lire la
pétition et pour les acteurs mise en
place par le centre de musique baroque
de versailles cet atelier s'inscrit dans
le projet génération lully une
cinquantaine d'élèves ont pu se
familiariser avec l'univers de la
comédie y avait beaucoup beaucoup
d'intérêt surtout pour les costumes
parce qu'ils n'ont pas l'habitude sont
quand même des costumes a l'habitude de
voir ni de toucher ni manipulée et
surtout pas d'enfiler et donc ils ont
été effectivement très fin très surpris
je pense toucher parce que ça fait
partie d'un certain patrimoine dans le
cadre de génération lully près de 1000
trappistes sont invités à participer à
ce type de découverte une action
éducative artistique et culturelle qui
va durer jusqu'en 2018